you've never had a sudden urge to take a
[ __ ] and you had no control
i've shed my pants before well there we
go i don't want to [ __ ] in my own pants
i was sad
oh you're a sexy i'm not being an adult
[ __ ] in my pants i like it three times a
day at least
oh you do i like to [ __ ] yeah i should
have the push or does it come out like
slide out no it comes out
yeah i'm good to go three meals three
shits that's how i do it do you take
long shits or short ones longer
30 mins but you're so you're conditioned
to [ __ ] at a certain time is that what
it is nope
you force it nope what it just happens
organically oh you sometimes i'll do
three shits before 3 p.m
when i was on riding on conan i was
right there and i was
laying awake in bed one morning like not
getting up yet and i was sleeping in
just
underwear yeah no shirt for some reason
i usually sleep in the shirt
and uh i just laying there and about you
know going
planning to fart
and just [ __ ] i just [ __ ] in my
underwear
and for some reason the fact that i was
in bed mostly naked it just really upset
me
and then my phone rang and it was my
friend dino who was my
one of my guys i wrote with on conan and
i told him what happened
i said i just feel so i don't want to
get out of bed now like i don't know
i just don't want to move this was the
grossest thing deal with it
and then i got out of bed i dealt you
know cleaned up and i went to work
and i opened the door and the writer's
assistant this woman says
hey i heard you [ __ ] your underwear this
morning i'm like what the [ __ ]
and every single person came up to me
conan said hey
what's up how did that go [ __ ] in your
underwear
and i said what the [ __ ] and he goes i
assumed you wanted me to tell everybody
why wouldn't i
why wouldn't you told me didn't you tell
me so i could spread the news before you
get to work
i took a [ __ ] so bad in japan this guy
next to me threw up one time
yeah where in japan
public restroom and he threw up next to
me i heard him throwing up
how do you know it's because of i was
it was so bad that's happened twice to
me that one time it happened in denver
i took a [ __ ] and the guy next to me
goes oh my god he's like dear god is
that you and he started gagging and i go
it's pretty bad right he was like
and i was like are you throwing up he's
like i can't i can't i gotta get out of
here
dude i remember in high school we did a
like a class trip of class
overnight trip where you go and you
spend the night in like the woods
somewhere
and we were junior in high school and it
was the morning and i go and you know
when you feel the gurgles you're like
this could be a nasty one it's gonna be
loud so i walk in and i'm going towards
the stall
and i see cliff one of my classmates
he's like what's up man
i do i'll go hey and i sit down and i'm
like
i'm gonna wait for him to get
comfortable because i know how bad this
is gonna be
yeah and i want him to be locked into it
you know but my [ __ ] is also like
you got a [ __ ] bad so i just i hold as
long as i can and he just i see him drop
his pants
he's in the stall next door and then i
release and it just goes like
like huge explosion and
within a second i just hear him go [ __ ]
this
and pull his pants up i think he had a
turret hanging out of his ass
just pulls his pants up and leaves
because and i just start laughing
so hard because i know how bad it sounds
and i know how bad it smells
he left the bathroom it was still like
one of my greatest high school memories
that's nice i was just telling someone
the worst i've ever shipped my pants
was um tennis camp i went
to uh i was playing this indian kid and
i had to [ __ ] really bad and i was like
oh my god so i just threw the set like i
lost
ran to the men's locker room and as soon
as i went to go get there
it was already kind of coming out and i
[ __ ]
inside my pants inside my underwear on
the tail of my shirt and in my socks
and i and i sat in it like i [ __ ] and i
sat in it
and i had to get rid of all my clothes i
had to break into a man's locker
and get clothes to wear because i didn't
have any they were all covered in [ __ ]
dude what is wrong with you guys like
don't you know how much are you sitting
now
no don't you know when you have to [ __ ]
why are you why are you waiting until
you i'm not [ __ ] on sundays
because i travel so i forget the [ __ ] on
sundays
and so mondays are bad today was [ __ ]
aggressive i got anxiety at the comedy
store one night
and i left there without going to the
bathroom
and on low canyon guys on the way up the
hill
my car was stinking like a [ __ ] blind
yard
i was about to [ __ ] but everybody's
doing that are you doing fun
it had to be 11 30 at night and right
there
passing ventura and laurel canyon as a
bank
yeah i went right behind the bank
i pulled over right i opened up the door
the three-point system you didn't even
know you were doing the three-point
system heeled over and what came out of
my ass was pure
wow it was like 17 inches there was
peanuts and
fingernails paper towels
[ __ ] and i threw it on top of the thing
and i shut the door and i'm like my
stomach was hurting and i took off and i
called lee and i go wait i just shipped
by the bank
and let me tell you something i went
there the next day to look at that
animal because that's the type of dude i
am
if i run if i run over yet at night come
back
take a look what happened it was gone
like they came and sandblasted it like
the people must have like
something drink cleaning somebody
cleaned it was
i can't go to that grocery store anymore
it's across the street it was
animalistic i live in new york too and
man there's
you can't get along with no money in new
york you got to live in these tiny
places i have this apartment right
and uh we have this okay here's the
toilet right i'm on the toilet this
house is called the apartment
the tub is right here like right next to
the toilet then there's a wall like
right [ __ ] here
like right there's no you gotta you get
squeezed in
and here's the worst part i have to put
a foot in the tub
to use this toilet because
otherwise i'm going to go like this who
shits like this with their knees
together
i'm pooping
to achieve this position i have to put a
foot in the tub
now try putting a foot in the tub when
your pants are your ankles you can't
they both want to go
right so i have to take off the whole
pant leg
which means i have to take a shoe off
every time i take a [ __ ]
every time
and sometimes that's okay but a lot of
times it [ __ ] isn't okay
sometimes i didn't plan effectively and
i'm 10 blocks from my house and i've got
a
[ __ ] you know when you you can't run
because you'll bounce it out so you got
to kind of
collide and you're going come on god
damn it
didn't you stop occasionally [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
come on man okay i gotta make it i'm
gonna make it i'm gonna make it i'm
gonna make it
i'm gonna make it and i always get at
this point like i'm gonna make it i'm
[ __ ] fine
i'm fine mind over matter i'm gonna make
it and then i see my house
i just see it and my eyes tell the rest
of me [ __ ] it man let go we're here
there's no need to hold on anymore
we've made it because my eyes are
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and they don't know the difference
between the outside and the inside of my
house
so now i got like olympic seconds to
[ __ ] get in my house and open the
door to bathroom and i gotta take a
[ __ ] shoe off
are you
i have [ __ ] my pants 13 times
oh shut up
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know my girl's like let's go get
something to eat and i said all right
there's a [ __ ] mcdonald's right there
and she's like
do you want to eat there and soda was
looking down at the ground all sad
you know just doing that classic female
manipulation thing
she knew i wanted to eat there i just
said there's a mcdonald's there
and then why would she say do you want
to eat there
and look down at the ground this
question is for all the young male
listeners of my whispering podcast
why would a female do that do
do do i'll tell you why
because she doesn't want to not only
does she not want to [ __ ] eat there
she already has a place where she wants
to eat she's our she's already had this
place
that she's want wanted to eat at for
probably a month before
you ever went to vegas but she's not
going to tell you about it
because if she told you about it that'd
give you time to do research on it
and find out how [ __ ] expensive it
was
so she's like do you want to eat that
she looks down at the ground so
immediately
despite the fact that i know all this
about females
i take the bait why where do you want to
eat sweetheart
um this is burger place at mandalay bay
i heard it was really nice that's a good
[ __ ] at mandalay bay the bad [ __ ] is we
go to this [ __ ] burger place i can't
remember the name of it we go in there
and i i order a 16.50
[ __ ] kobe beef burger and they're
talking about how it's the greatest
goddamn burger
all you know the highest quality [ __ ]
meat yada
[ __ ] yatta my girl orders one too 16
50 and 16.50 what is that kids
that's 33 bucks plus fries plus drinks
all that [ __ ] you know the mob
doesn't run vegas anymore you can't go
out and get yourself a two dollar steak
the whole [ __ ] place out there now is
a goddamn it's a [ __ ] over
so whatever cost me like 40 something
bucks 50 bucks with the goddamn tip
i eat it you know what wasn't even that
good
my girl's like how's your burger you
know what i said i said it's good
just keeping the peace keeping the water
nice and smooth
nice and [ __ ] still on the horizon
okay so anyways
i get back to my hotel my girl already
tells me she doesn't feel too good
that that burger's sitting in her like a
goddamn boot and i'm like you know what
i feel fine
i get ready to do my show iron my
button-down shirt
put a little conditioner in my hair
what's left of it shape it up
a little and i head downstairs
to go work the orleans casino the last
place carlin ever worked
the place where the smothers brothers
retired
so anyways i walk down there and i'm
going through the orleans casino and
then all of a sudden it just [ __ ]
hits me
boom right my stomach like some capsule
some time release cia
you're gonna [ __ ] your pants [ __ ]
capsule goes off
and i know there is no question that
whatever i just ate
was not good for my body and it was
about to reject it
one way or the other without getting
crude people
when something goes into your stomach if
it's coming out
it only has two options all right
anyways
i just thought of a really really bad
joke for the [ __ ] third one and i'm
not gonna say
it but it involved stabbing yourself in
the stomach
and you can fill in the blanks on that
one all right
so anyways um
tommy you gotta be [ __ ] you gotta be
[ __ ] me no pun
intended so i go in the back way
the same way that carlin used to go in
because i've already
asked everybody every [ __ ] question
literally how much i'm into carlin
how did he leave did he hang out no he'd
say goodnight he would grow right out
the door and he'd be in the car
and he wasn't difficult to work with i
guess he had arthritis at the end of his
life and uh
the sound guy was saying one show he
forgot to take the bottle caps off the
water
bottles and he saw that carolyn was
struggling with them
and when he got off because george i'm
so sorry i'm so sorry and joe's just
like
whack ow come on come on i don't give a
[ __ ] don't worry just walked out i guess
he was a really great guy
so anyways i'm walking through this
legendary
door and uh
you know and what's worse is like i know
it's gonna happen
but i know it's not gonna happen for
like another 15 minutes
and coincidentally the [ __ ] show
starts in 15 minutes and i'm going on
first
all right and this guy when you're
backstage
literally says 20 minutes till show time
20 minutes till showtime he like counts
it down
i never get nervous before shows but
this guy counting down the show is
making me nervous
15 minutes till showtime okay and it's
starting to get worse and [ __ ] it
literally gets down to two minutes
before showtime
and i'm questioning can i make it
through a half hour set
and i was like you know what [ __ ] this
the show can't start without me my
opening music is elvis presley anyways
the [ __ ] do i care they can listen to
that song
i'm gonna rub my fingers through your
long black hair
slam your [ __ ] face off the [ __ ]
sink
i don't give a [ __ ] and i said [ __ ] it
and i
[ __ ] ran into the bathroom and i will
spare you
the details but you know when something
either amazing
or uh something amazing happens they
make a statue
if something horrific happens a lot of
times they will preserve
the area you know like dealey plaza
[ __ ] president gets his brains blown
out all of a sudden we can't
change one blade of [ __ ] grass
the horror that happened in that [ __ ]
bathroom ladies and gentlemen i never do
[ __ ] jokes
they should have retired that [ __ ]
bathroom
that's it they should have just [ __ ]
uh
air sealed it and just put a glass
[ __ ] door
so people could look in and and realize
why they closed that [ __ ] burger
joint
at the mandalay bay and uh i gotta admit
dude i have i haven't
this is it's monday i'm finally back to
normal
so there you go there's my big [ __ ]
story i had a burger
over at the [ __ ] mandalay bay
and it almost ruined my [ __ ] show
over at the orleans
so if you guys saw me anybody saw me
saturday night
all right you want to talk about a
professional because i extra [ __ ]
killed on that show
if you knew what the [ __ ] happened just
know that
the next time you go to vegas
and you go to see barry manilow and he's
singing that song
mandy you something you something
and you something but i still wanna [ __ ]
you
oh mandy right just know
that he could have just been [ __ ]
his [ __ ] brains out
two minutes before he put on his rayon
[ __ ] slacks
with his horrific plastic surgery his
yank back face i bet you know
i was gonna say he'd be in another
facelift if he [ __ ] [ __ ] the way i
did before my show
but that's actually not true there's no
strain there was no straining
anyways all right bill jesus christ
enough already